Healthcare is all about meeting the needs of a
community and data science can help meet those
needs a little better. Specifically, when we
talk about meeting the community’s needs, what
do we mean? Well, there are three major categories
perhaps. The first one is identifying the needs.
Second, it is about optimizing delivery.
Getting those needs met quickly and efficiently.
And third, assessing effectiveness to see
how well you’re doing and see if there’s
ways that you can change the services
to better meet those communities needs.
Let’s talk about optimizing delivery
and assessing effectiveness.
When it comes to optimizing delivery, there’s
several aspects that data science can contribute
to. The first one is, in terms of just logistics.
For example, coordinating the emergency department
functions, so when a person arrives in an
emergency room, there’s a wide range of
tasks to perform including things like, drawing
blood, getting x-rays or ultrasounds, obtaining
medication, and so on. Simply determining the
order in which these tasks should be performed,
not meaning always in the same order, but
according to what’s happening to this particular
person, what else is going on in the ER, the
time of day. Determining the order and matching
the staffing, the resources, can also make a big
difference. For example, some hospitals created a
model to predict patient demand for each category
of lab tests, by time of day and day of week.
So, it’s an optimization model.
And the result is that they were
able to reduce average patient wait time for
lab tests, by 75%, from one hour to 15 minutes.
Second, there’s operating room schedules. The ORs
in the hospital, are one of the busiest, and one
of the most important places in the hospital. They
account for 60% of admissions and also 60% of the
revenue of the hospital. But, in most hospitals,
the operating rooms are scheduled by phone calls,
or faxes, or emails. That makes scheduling
slow and it’s also awkward to make changes.
For instance, when a surgeon ends up not
needing the room for as long as he anticipated.
They are actually also less likely to make
those changes because the process is awkward.
So this is an area that is ripe for tech. For
example, UC Health in Colorado went through a
relatively simple process of creating a smartphone
app, that could schedule the operating rooms. And
they found that surgeons increased the number of
scheduled blocks that they released, by nearly
50%, and did so 10% sooner. And that freed up some
of the most valuable resources in the hospital.
One of the interesting element of
optimizing delivery is discharge planning.
When a person has received the help they needed
at a hospital and it’s time for them to leave.
Simple problems like verifying their insurance,
or even having a ride home can slow things down.
Hospitals like MedStar Georgetown University
Hospital in Washington, D.C., they developed
models that helped them predict bottlenecks
in discharge as soon as the patient checks in.
This allowed to increase their daily discharge
volume, by over 20% and reduce the length of stay,
that is the time spent just waiting to get out,
by half a day. Again, an immense improvement in
efficiency, that allows the hospital to devote
their resource to other people who need it,
as opposed to people who are just
waiting to get out of the building.
There is also the matter of assessing
effectiveness. How well is the hospital performing
its functions and can it do so in a way that’s
both, more time effective and more cost effective.
Well, there’s several elements to this. One of
them, for instance, is reducing readmission.
Hospital visits are expensive and while it
saves money to not keep people there any
longer than they need, it really is problematic
and much more expensive, to send somebody out
too soon or with inadequate support. So they end
up having to come back again for the same issue.
There’s also reducing health
problems for premature babies.
For instance, at some hospitals, researchers
using high-frequency physiological data,
such as heart rate and respiration rate, to
create algorithms that can predict when a
premature baby is at risk of infection and other
health complications. Now what’s really amazing
about this, is these algorithms are able to
identify the tell-tale signs of infection,
in changes in their heart rate, up 24 hours
before the infection takes hold. This allows
the hospital time to take preventive action
and potentially save the life of the newborn.
There’s also the matter of reducing travel time
for healthcare. Depending on where you live, you
may have to travel for hours to see, for example,
a specialist in a rare form of cancer, or even for
something as common as reproductive health. Data
science algorithms can help hospitals and clinics,
identity which locations are at greatest need
for specific services, and also determine the
schedules that would best match the availability
of the people who need those services.
You can also improve effectiveness by looking
at something like, how well are your program
reducing the waiting time to see healthcare
professionals? Doctor’s offices are notorious for
long wait times. It would be nice if the patient
can come in and out of there in 15 minutes.
The system can use the information that you had
given them previously, that they were able to
gather information passively, that this sharing
between organizations was seamless so that you
didn’t have to provide the same information over
and over and over again, and that scheduling
could be better coordinated so that there
was less time waiting and lagging between.
All of these things taken together, the ability
to identify the places of greatest need,
the ability to coordinate care effectively,
the ability to assess effectiveness,
all of these, are ways that data science can
help make the provision of healthcare more
effective and really, more beneficial
to the communities that they serve.